The Long Now, and The Clock of the Long Now, is about planning for the long-term and
thinking in the long-term in a world in
which people appear to be thinking in
the shorter and shorter term. Tom Sebok
concluded you couldn't actually create a
story that would last 10,000 years; you
could only create a story that would
last for three generations: for ourselves,
for our children, for their children.
But what we can do, I think, is try and create stories that are interesting enough, and important enough
that our grandchildren might want to tell
those stories to their grandchildren.
Because that's the purpose of stories.
It's what they're for. They make life worth
living. And sometimes, they keep us alive.